et donc à la société,
de l'ordre de 380 milliards de dollars par an.
On pense tous à certains exemples.
Les secrets de l'industrie automobile ne sont plus si secrets.
La fraude est devenue une caractéristique,
pas un bug,
de l'industrie des services financiers.
Ce n'est pas moi qui prétends cela,
c'est le président de l'American Finance Association
qui a déclaré ça dans son discours présidentiel.
C'est un énorme problème si vous pensez, en particulier,
à une économie comme la Suisse
qui repose tant sur la confiance en son secteur financier.
D'un autre côté,
il y a six entreprises sur sept qui restent vraiment honnêtes
malgré toutes les tentations à frauder.
Il y a des lanceurs d'alerte comme Michael Woodford
qui a dénoncé Olympus.
Ces lanceurs d'alerte risquent leur carrière,
leurs amitiés,
pour dévoiler la vérité sur leurs entreprises.
Il y a des journalistes, comme Anna Politkovskaya,
qui risquent leur vie pour signaler les violations des droits de l'Homme.
Elle a été tuée.
Chaque année,
une centaine de journalistes sont tués
à cause de leur conviction pour dévoiler la vérité.
Dans mon discours aujourd'hui,
je veux partager avec vous des idées que j'ai obtenues et apprises
au cours des dix dernières années de recherches dans ce domaine.
Je suis un chercheur, un scientifique qui travaille avec des économistes,
des économistes financiers,
des éthiciens, des neuroscientifiques,
des avocats etc.
On essaie de comprendre ce qui motive les humains
et comment on peut aborder la question de la fraude dans les entreprises,
et ainsi améliorer le monde.
Je veux commencer par vous faire part de deux visions très distinctes
sur le comportement des gens.
D'abord, voici Adam Smith,
père-fondateur de l'économie moderne.
Son idée de base est que, si tout le monde sert ses propres intérêts,
au final, c'est bon pour tout le monde.
L'intérêt personnel n'est pas un concept défini de façon étroite,
juste pour une utilité immédiate.
Il a une implication à long terme.
Réfléchissons-y.
Prenez ce chien, là.
Ça pourrait être nous.
Il y a cette tentation, là.
Je présente mes excuses aux végétariens,
(Rires)
mais les chiens aiment les « bratwurst ».
Donc, l'action directe et égoïste,
c'est d'y aller, là.
Donc, mon ami Adam pourrait sauter,
attraper la saucisse, et de fait détruire toute cette belle vaisselle.
Mais ce n'est pas ce qu'Adam Smith voulait dire.
Il ne voulait pas dire de mépriser les conséquences,
au contraire.
Il aurait pensé :
« Il peut y avoir des conséquences négatives. »
Par exemple,
le maître du chien sera fâché après lui.
Anticipant cela, le chien ne se comportera peut-être pas comme ça.
Ça pourrait être nous,
pesant le pour et le contre de nos actions.
Comment ça marche ?
Je suis sûr que beaucoup d'entre vous,
avez, dans vos entreprises,
surtout si elle est grande,
un code de conduite.
Et si vous suivez ce code de conduite,
vous avez plus de chance de recevoir un bonus.
A l'inverse, si vous ne le respectez pas,
il y a plus de chances pour que vous n'obteniez pas de bonus
ou qu'il soit moindre.
En d'autres termes,
c'est un moyen très économique
pour faire en sorte que les gens soient plus honnêtes
ou plus respectueux des principes de l'entreprise.
La réputation est aussi une force économique très puissante, non ?
On essaie d'avoir la réputation
de quelqu'un d'honnête,
pour que les gens se fient plus à nous à l'avenir.
Non ?
Adam Smith parlait du boulanger
qui produisait du pain, non pas par bienveillance
par rapport à ceux qui le consommaient,
mais parce qu'il voulait en vendre plus dans le futur.
Dans mon étude, on voit, par exemple,
à l'Université de Zurich,
que les banques suisses qui se retrouvent dans les médias
dans des contextes
d'évasion fiscale ou de fraude fiscale,
ont une couverture médiatique négative.
Elles perdent de l'argent frais,
et font donc moins de profits.
C'est la très grande force de la réputation.
Bénéfices et coûts.
Voici un autre point de vue sur le monde.
Voici Emmanuel Kant,
philosophe « vedette » allemand du 18ème siècle.
Il a développé la notion
selon laquelle, qu'importent les conséquences,
certaines actions sont purement bonnes, d'autres purement mauvaises.
C'est mal de mentir, par exemple.
Donc, voici mon ami Emmanuel, là.
Il sait que la saucisse est très bonne,
mais il va faire demi-tour parce que c'est un bon chien.
Il sait que c'est mal de sauter,
et de risquer de casser toute cette belle vaisselle.
Si vous pensez que les gens agissent comme ça,
tous les trucs sur la « carotte »,
tous les trucs sur le code de conduite et le système de primes
n'ont plus aucun sens.
Les gens sont peut être poussés par différentes valeurs.
Par quoi les gens sont-ils motivés en fait ?
Ces deux gentlemen ont une coiffure parfaite,
mais ils nous donnent des visions du monde très différentes.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait de ça ?
Bon, en tant qu'économiste,
on fait ce qu'on appelle des expériences pour aborder ce problème.
On se débarrasse des faits qui nous embrouillent dans la réalité.
La réalité est très dense, il se passe plein de choses,
c'est presque impossible de savoir en vrai ce qui motive le comportement des gens.
Donc, faisons ensemble une petite expérience.
Imaginez la situation suivante.
Vous êtes seul dans une pièce,
pas comme ici.
Devant vous, il y a une pièce de 5 francs
comme celle que je tiens maintenant.
Voici vos instructions :
tirez quatre fois à pile ou face,
puis, sur l'ordinateur en face de vous,
entrez le nombre de fois où vous êtes tombé sur pile.
C'est ça, la situation.
Et voilà le truc.
A chaque fois que vous annoncez que vous avez obtenu pile,
vous êtes payé cinq francs.
Donc si vous dites que vous avez eu deux fois pile,
vous êtes payé 10 francs.
Si vous dites zéro, vous êtes payé zéro francs.
Si vous dites : « J'ai eu quatre pile »,
vous êtes donc payé 20 francs.
C'est anonyme,
personne ne regarde ce que vous faites,
et on vous paie anonymement.
Je vous pose deux questions.
(Rires)
Vous savez ce qui vient, non ?
D'abord, comment agiriez-vous dans cette situation ?
Deuxièmement, regardez à gauche et à droite...
(Rires)
réfléchissez à ce que ferait la personne assise à côté de vous
dans cette situation.
On a fait cette expérience en vrai.
On l'a faite à la Manifesta Art Exhibition
qui a eu lieu récemment à Zurich,
pas avec des étudiants au labo de l'université
mais avec de vraies gens,
comme vous.
Tout d'abord, un petit rappel des statistiques.
Si je lance la pièce quatre fois, et que c'est une pièce équilibrée,
la probabilité pour la pièce tombe quatre fois du côté pile
est de 6,25%.
Et j'espère que vous pouvez d'instinct voir
que la probabilité d'avoir quatre fois pile est bien plus basse
que celle d'avoir deux fois pile.
Voici les nombres précis.
Voici ce qui s'est passé.
Des gens ont vraiment fait l'expérience.
Environ 30 à 35% des gens ont dit :
« Je suis tombé quatre fois sur pile ».
C'est extrêmement peu probable.
(Rires)
Mais la chose vraiment incroyable ici,
enfin, pour un économiste,
c'est qu'environ 65% n'ont pas dit qu'ils avaient eu quatre fois pile
même si dans cette situation,
personne ne vous regarde,
la seule conséquence,
c'est de gagner plus d'argent si vous dites quatre plutôt que moins.
Vous laissez 20 francs sur la table si vous dites zéro.
Je ne sais pas si les autres étaient tous honnêtes
ou s'ils ont dit un peu plus ou moins que ce qu'ils ont vraiment obtenu,
parce que c'est anonyme.
On a juste observé la distribution.
Mais ce que je peux vous dire... Encore un essai, voilà !
C'est pile.
(Rires)
Ne vérifiez pas, hein ?
Ce que je peux vous dire,
c'est que tout le monde n'a pas réagi comme Adam Smith l'aurait prédit.
Donc qu'est-ce qu'il nous reste ?
Eh bien, il semble que les gens soient motivés par des valeurs intrinsèques
et dans notre recherche, on étudie ça.
On regarde le fait que les gens ont des valeurs dites « protégées ».
Une valeur « protégée » n'est pas n'importe quelle valeur.
C'est une valeur pour laquelle vous voulez payer un prix
dans le but de la garder.
Vous voulez payer un prix pour résister à la tentation d'abandonner cette valeur.
Et la conséquence, c'est que vous vous sentez mieux
si vous gagnez l'argent selon une méthode qui correspond à vos valeurs.
Laissez-moi vous montrer ça de nouveau avec la métaphore de notre fameux chien.
Si on arrive à attraper la saucisse sans aller à l'encontre de nos valeurs,
la saucisse aura meilleur goût.
C'est ce que montre notre recherche.
Si, au contraire,
on fait...
si on obtient la saucisse
et en faisant ça, on va à l'encontre de nos valeurs,
on attachera moins d'importance à la saucisse.
En terme de rendement, c'est assez puissant.
On peut mesurer ces valeurs « protégées »,
par exemple,
avec une enquête.
Une enquête simple, en neuf points, assez prédictive dans ces expériences.
Si on pense à la moyenne de la population
puis il y a la distribution autour,
les gens sont différents, on est tous différents.
Les gens qui ont un lot de valeurs « protégées »
qui dépasse la moyenne d'une unité,
réduisent la valeur de l'argent reçu en mentant, d'environ 25%.
Cela veut dire qu'un dollar reçu quand ils mentent
ne vaut pour eux que 75 centimes
sans qu'aucune motivation à être honnête n'ait été mise en place.
C'est leur motivation intrinsèque.
Au fait, je ne suis pas une autorité morale,
je ne dis pas que j'ai moi-même toutes ces belles valeurs, ok ?
Mais je m'intéresse au comportement des gens
et à comment on peut se servir cette richesse de la nature humaine
pour améliorer réellement le fonctionnement de nos organisations.
Il y a deux visions très très différentes.
D'un côté,
on peut faire appel aux bienfaits et coûts,
faire en sorte que les gens se comportent en fonction de ça.
D'un autre côté,
on peut recruter les gens qui ont les valeurs
et bien sûr les caractéristiques voulues,
les compétences, qui sont conformes à votre organisation.
Je ne sais pas encore d'où viennent réellement ces valeurs « protégées ».
Est-ce l'éducation ou la nature ?
Ce que je peux vous dire,
c'est que la distribution semble similaire chez les hommes et les femmes.
Elle a l'air semblable chez ceux qui ont étudié l'économie
et ceux qui ont étudié la psychologie.
Elle semble similaire à différents âges
chez les adultes.
Mais je ne sais pas comment ça évolue à long terme.
Ça sera le sujet de recherches futures.
L'idée que je voudrais que vous reteniez,
c'est que ce n'est pas mal de faire appel à la « carotte »,
- je suis économiste -
bien sûr que je crois au fait que la « carotte » fonctionne.
Mais réfléchissez à ça : recruter les bonnes personnes
plutôt que des gens pour qui on doit mettre en place la « carotte ».
Recruter les bonnes personnes avec les bonnes valeurs
pourrait contribuer à éviter beaucoup de difficultés
et à économiser beaucoup d'argent
dans vos organisations.
En d'autres mots,
mettre en avant l'humain portera ses fruits.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)